welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight that's eight five five at two
three six thirty to twenty eight Melissa
in Jacksonville Florida you're on the
bench bureau of the heart Melissa hey
Ben um I had a question for you what are
your thoughts with the upcoming election
right around the corner all the looting
and rioting taking places our cities
being held hostage our officers being
attacked and assaulted and president
Trump not taking a harder stance just
you know we're gonna do something but
then he doesn't do anything and it's
getting worse it's getting way worse
yeah I mean I look I think that the
president Trump's tough talk needs to be
translated into tougher action I mean he
keeps tweeting things out about how he's
going to stop what's going on in Seattle
but then then he doesn't in Governor
Reagan right when Ronald Reagan was
governor of California there was a very
well publicized event when he was
governor of California where Berkeley
student protesters and rioters took over
the offices at Berkeley and they took
over a space at Berkeley and he
literally brought in tanks I mean I
don't think that Trump has to do that
but the fact that he appears to be sort
of saying either say nothing and then
and then quietly push policy or come out
there and express that you are going to
do something and do something but it
appears weak when you say law and order
and then you don't actually do anything
or when you say that we won't allow this
in Seattle and then you just don't do
anything like that that's not a good
look by the way right now if you are a
small town there's never been a better
time in history if you're a small town
to recruit good police officers
seriously like if I if I were the mayor
of a small town I would be offering
twenty thousand dollar bonuses to any
major city police officer with the clean
record to come and work for me because
my goodness I mean if you're a police
officer in a major city why would you
want to work in a major city under the
conditions that have now been placed
upon you by local government which is
allowing people to run roughshod over
police officers not defending police
officers even in defensible situations
and that the the right has a campaign
platform here and that is you know what
the precondition to any sort of fund in
Liberty is in woful Society you know
what Democrats are willing to allow to
happen they're willing to allow all of
this to slip back into chaos and they
and we've been watching it
how has the Trump campaign not put out
an ad just in various Democratic
politicians basically pooh-poohing the
rioting in the looting how is the Trump
campaign not put
material pointing out that Democratic
mayor's have been allowing this stuff to
occur in their cities like it's
political malpractice I am astonished at
the level of political malpractice by
the Trump campaign I mean it's
frustrating because as somebody whose
plans on voting for Trump I do not
understand how it like he'll have they
not put out an ad already on kovat that
says here's here's a a giant compendium
of all the Democratic governors saying
they got what they needed from from
right and then the media just lying
about it right how is that possible like
this is this is the run a campaign but
if you think that you're gonna run
everything from Twitter it ain't gonna
work that way and as you say like I
don't think most Americans are on board
with the rioting and the looting I think
there's a certain species of woke
liberal white women in the suburbs as
reported by the Washington Post who are
who are trying to convince themselves
that rioting and looting are just the
expressions of discontent of the
oppressed classes but I don't think that
most people deep down believe that
because they want to treat people as
individuals and they believe that no
matter how bad things were 400 years ago
or 50 years ago or no matter how bad
your home life was you don't get to just
shatter the windows at a target and walk
away with the TV it's just like there's
no accountability and it's time we're
ready for him to act his supporters
Trump supporters are tired of seeing
this we're ready for him to do something
he's losing my respect by not acting by
not doing something yeah I mean I think
that that's exactly right I think that's
exactly right I think that people voted
for Trump and they backed Trump because
they saw him as the staff gap between
what the left wants and us right I mean
that really is what what Trump was if
you ask Trump supporters I didn't
support him because of the tweeting they
didn't support him because he was so
brash and bold they supported him
because he was this this solid wall that
was going to stand against bad left
policy that was destructive to the
country well I've never seen a bad left
policies destructive to the country is a
week-long shutdown of all major city
services because you have to let rioters
and looters run rampant and then the
president's big response to that was I'm
gonna tweet some stuff I'm gonna say
some stuff again this is coming from
somebody who is again I plan on voting
for the man but I understand why people
are disillusioned with the with the
notion that if the wall doesn't hold and
it's just a bunch of tweets then what
exactly did Republicans get for the
bargain like yes better than the
alternative but you can't you can't
portray yourself as the as the leader of
the
the strong strength stand against
weakness Brigade and then basically your
response amounts to I'm gonna go on TV
and I'm gonna say mean things about the
mayor of Seattle well that's always
going to bash him whatever he does or
doesn't do at this point in time I
continue to listen to his supporters the
ones that voted him in and put a stop to
all of this stop it by the way if he
fell in the middle of the rioting and
the looting if you'd said listen you
guys don't have your cities under
control
I'm calling the insurrection act we're
gonna send in the we're gonna send in
the the the military I mean as Tom
cotton suggested and we're gonna stop
this thing dead it's done we're not
going to allow this kind of rampant
looting and destruction wrap and allow
your mayor's to basically sacrifice your
rights on behalf of criminality if he
had done that he would've gotten a lot
of blowback in the moment and then he
would've been able to put out a bunch of
ads saying you know who stopped the
rioting and the looting in your cities
it was me Wow right and and like
politically speaking put aside the right
and wrong of it Melissa I appreciate the
call Jonah in Michigan you're on the
bench parish I'll go for Jonah hi Ben my
question for you um as a 23 year old
pursuing his bachelor's degree I am very
predominately conservative and as things
go on I you know personally I don't
believe in systemic racism I don't
believe in looting as I move towards
universities in Michigan it's very
liberal based what would your advice be
to someone that doesn't want to
sacrifice their academic achievements
doesn't want to give up their moral and
beliefs integrity yeah I've said this to
so many students over the years I have a
very large difference of opinion with my
good friend Dennis Prager on this so
Dennis Prager is is always with mind you
speak up and you speak out and damn the
consequences and I think Dennis he went
to college in 1970 like that's that's
not that's not how this thing works
right now why you would give a weapon to
your political enemies to destroy your
career is beyond me you have to
determine for yourself what is the
purpose of each conversation is the
outcome something that you're looking
for that is possible or is it just use
venting spleen right into this every day
and your interactions with family are
your family members you have a
disagreement so you know you could say
something really harmful to them you can
win the argument but the cost may be
worth more than benefit well the same
thing happens in academia but it is just
a simple fact of life that people do
need to keep their heads down in many
cases in the academic world in order to
get ahead and you can rebel against that
you
shout about it but the predictable
consequences of that are quite real so
you have to determine when you can take
it when you can't you have to determine
what your alternatives are like I always
encourage everybody to really think
through the purpose of what they are
doing on a day to day level because that
is the way to lead a rewarding life now
that doesn't mean that you can't lead a
rebellion against that if you think
that's something that's likely to
succeed or if you're willing to take the
El so willing to take the loss just to
make a point I sometimes think that's
worthwhile I've done it myself but I
think that people don't think this stuff
through and very often it's like I'm mad
I'm putting something up on Facebook and
then there's a predictable consequence
isn't that bad yes it is very bad also
you damaged yourself and now you two
things can be true you can be right and
also you could have done something that
wasn't particularly useful absolutely I
I completely agree and I agree with you
on picking and choosing their battles
especially when there's so much on the
line and a lot of people that post on
Facebook they have no reprimand form of
consequences or accountabilities it's so
shareable it's so common so I completely
agree with you and I really do
appreciate your advice on that yeah you
bet Jonah I think it honestly I think
it's a more liveable standard than say
what you want whenever you want then
expect the world to conform to your to
your opinions John in Phoenix Arizona
you're on the bench Peoria Park John
yeah I just had a quick question about
what's going on with NASCAR what's their
fan base knowing sometimes their races
and watch us buy their merchandise how
do you feel about them taking down the
Confederate flag how do I feel that now
I mean NASCAR's a private organization I
think they can do whatever they want I
think that them buying into the
narrative that everybody flying a
confederate flag is a racist is is
ridiculous I think that they ought to
recognize that a lot of their fans are
people who fly the Confederate flag on
their trucks as a as a sign of sympathy
for sort of southern regional pride
having nothing to do with the actual
Confederacy and having nothing to do
with slavery and racism I understand
it's a branding matter why NASCAR
wouldn't want a bunch of Confederate
flags flying at a time when they're
trying to broaden out their constituency
so you know let's put this way I have
less of a problem with NASCAR saying we
don't want Confederate flags here than I
do with NASCAR saying it's totally fine
Danneel for the national anthem right I
think those are two very different
things I think that you can say I think
the Confederate flag is alienating to a
lot of our fan base once you start
saying the American flag is very
alienating to a lot of our fan base I
think you've gone too far you know it
makes a lot of sense now that you put
like that completely agree review I
appreciate it John thanks for the call
Riley in Florida you're on the bench
beer sir go for it Riley hey Ben how are
you a big fan thank you for having me so
my question to you is so I'm actually
about to start my career as a law
enforcement officer my small home town
in Florida in a few weeks and obviously
with all this negativity going on
towards law enforcement and all the
disbanding and defunding of police I
just want to hear your opinion as far as
you know what steps we actually should
take as far as if we're going to defund
the police and what exactly is the left
looking to put this money into because
if I'm not mistaken you know a lot of
less were the ones who wanted you know
Pitt to ban guns for citizens and have
the police have you know higher forces
and more numbers and now all the sudden
they're like let's disband and reform
and get rid of the police yeah this is
exactly right one of the things that
you've been seeing is people lying about
how budgeting works so for example in
Los Angeles you'll see them say well
look at this one-third of the LA budget
is focused in on the police and the
other two-thirds are focused in on
social services why is it why that
proportion is way too high yes because
when it comes to school and education
one-third of the state budget is focused
on education like not all sources of
money are the same the city doesn't pay
for local schools in la la USD is not
paid for specifically by the LA City
Council it is paid for in part by local
property taxes but it is paid for in
large measure by the state of California
failing to acknowledge that there are
different sources of money that the LA
City taxes generally pay for the cops
the county and state taxes generally pay
for education that is that's a mistake
that a lot of people are making when
they look at the numbers like I should
have to look at the overall amount of
money spent on education in your area
from all sources versus the amount spent
on police but again I don't think these
are mutually exclusive
the notion that you are going to shift
resources from the cops to mental health
services I don't understand why we
wouldn't just increase the amount of
money you're spending on mental health
services these places are blowing out
the taxes anyway where is all this money
going it's going to a bunch of social
workers by the way the social workers
are not solving these problems hey you
can increase unemployment benefits that
is not solving the problem of violent
crime in these areas we've had
unemployment benefits we spent five
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
it has not solved the problem of vast
crime gaps in in major American cities
between racial groups those disparities
have not been solved by spending
disproportionate amounts of state
taxpayer dollars in those areas right
the answer here if you want to solve
crime is you need more cops everybody
knows it Joe Biden knows it I mean if
you ask Joe Biden has been saying it Joe
Biden was asked about to fund the
release he said well maybe we actually
might need to increase the police
everybody's ignoring that because they
want to pretend that everybody who's Pro
police is outside the mainstream but
everybody knows that the police are the
the line between civilization and
Anarchy we saw that over the past week
and if I were as I said before if I were
running a local area if I were mayor of
a local area I would be offering bonuses
to good police officers to move to my
area and work there I'd make my town the
safest town that I could and I'm
bewildered by the idea that you're gonna
make me unsafe or by defunding the cops
I mean the it by the way the idea that
mental illness workers should be first
line of should be first line of defense
when it comes to there's a homeless guy
in the street talking to himself I don't
disagree with that I I get that but the
idea that I agreed upon mental health
worker when that guy on the street who's
talked to himself is also running around
with a knife is insane I mean that's
that's not the same exactly of course
and I agree with you as far as far as
the small towns you know increasing the
pay you know I work in a small town that
is uh permit upper-middle class town and
they have been upping the pay and
increasing the salaries because again it
is a dangerous shawl officers reclaim
their lives online every single day you
know and really don't get a lot of
respect for it and I believe the amount
of pay that was around here was
substantial to what it should have been
and they're moving it up which I
appreciate and it's not just that you
know being you know going into law
enforcement is obviously something
that's very difficult nowadays and you
know of course I have people that attack
me for it all the time but you know what
like I stay proud about it you know I
hope all my brothers and sisters in blue
stay positive towards it and you know
we'll get through this situation in a
positive light at least I hope so yeah I
mean that that would certainly be nice
because this is a really really negative
situation and again people castigating
police are the first people to call cops
the minute something goes wrong the same
you know what cops are after all that
Berklee School of Music banning their
toilets to the cops
guess who's Berkeley's gonna call the
minute the front window gets smashed
they're not gonna be calling the tube is
it it's alright II appreciate the call
Riley we're gonna take more of your
calls in one moment at 8:5 5 2 3 6 32 28
that's 8 5 5 2 3 6 32:28 you're
listening to the ben shapiro show